sometimes just get a little sassy
sometimes a little too sassy sexy pants
everybody's got a question
hi welcome to ask IJ episode number 15
Justine what have you been lately not
making videos chill out I've been on
vacation I've been taking some time away
from the computer
here at the beach at the beach it's good
to get outside every once in a while
just not too often in my BP so one of
the first questions you're probably
gonna ask is just seeing where the heck
are you I'm at the TWiT cottage with the
hex twit cottage
it's where Leo Laporte hosts all of his
shows twit stands for this week in
technology all right so we got a first
question here and it's for my website
it's from Annie
Justine do you like to dance now Annie
if you've seen any of my videos you know
that I like to dance but the real
question is am I good at dancing and the
answer to that is no
not to be redundant or anything but I
got a youtube comment question asking me
what my favorite iPhone app is do you
wanna quesadilla and I wanna go would
have a dance party Waker clever people
I'm saying stop it
you're you're really I'm gonna punch you
stop it and that app is called smack
talk find it in the App Store my friends
if you had to have a facial piercing
which would it be
hi Rachel you know that's a great
question so I'm gonna present you with a
few options and let me know what you
think I'm definitely a fan of that last
one I mean I know it's not a piercing
but that's okay so I posted a video on
youtube.com slash other iJustine and on
that video I asked you guys to name my
pig there was an overwhelming response
for the pig to be named Shane Dawson
so congratulations Shane Dawson you got
your wish you little spammer well that's
it for episode number I don't know like
15 or something ask questions by leaving
comments below add video responses ask
questions on Twitter and of course
asking questions on the vlog and I just
you know calm I'll see you guys next
time peace out oh and don't forget to
click subscribe because if you don't
subscribe to my videos I'm gonna cry
thanks and have a nice day